right Lincoln Riley set to join us the
Oklahoma head coach joining us
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
if Baker Mayfield and Kyler Murray call
at the same time who's called do you
take well tea now you can take all three
at the same time so I'll take them both
all right all right if you're reliant
you are looking for if your wife or
Jalen Hurd's calls my wife
I'll call jaylen Bay how often you stay
in touch with Baker and Kyler pretty
often please we talk we talk weekly just
normally beginning of the week or or
maybe after our games I mean they don't
get a chance to talk to us and try to
catch them a little bit of them on
Sunday so normally a quick recap and I
were doing and tour a couple jabs at
each other and then and then wish each
other good luck do you break down
anything that they're doing or they ask
for them no not normally not normally
they might they might see something that
we're doing and ask about it or vice
versa we may see something that they're
doing and asked a quick question but
normally it's kind of just check an eye
in on them and a little more casual how
important are they as far as recruiting
goes that you know you seem to be this
Heisman pipeline there they are I mean
what they've done here their success and
coming from from different backgrounds
certainly is and then they're still very
involved with this with this program
they still do a lot of things with us
they still come back often involved with
our current team I recruit so there
shortly very important what loyalty do
you have to the kids you recruit as a
freshman as opposed to you bring in
jaylen hurts you bring in Baker Kyler as
well but those kids that you're
recruiting and they come in
how much loyalty do you have to them at
that position I mean I have volunteer
those guys but I wouldn't say any more
than I have with with jaylen now I think
you know your relationship gets you know
with them at different points right you
know you know most guys longer you know
been through more with those guys at
this point right here
but I would say I wouldn't say any more
loyalty to them than anybody else I you
know there's a great great relationship
there that was built for a lot but
loyalty I would say it's not any
different you scored 49 70-48 55 45 34
52 so far this season what is the big
secret what's the main ingredient for
that kind of offensive success okay I
think it just I don't think to play good
football at any level at any any side of
the ball it takes a lot of people on the
same page we have that with our staff we
have that we've got that with our
players differing skill set we've got a
good creative room as far as our
offensive guys but they've done a
tremendous job and then our and we've
had good players you know we've been
able to build it around what they do
well and and I think they you know
they're least you know they've created a
standard of success here that feels like
each group you know pills filled the
need and desire to you know to live up
to that or try to even take it further
yeah but you're doing something here
Lincoln because everybody's noticing
certainly the NFL is noticing these
quarterbacks are putting up huge numbers
jaylen comes in now people are looking
at him as a you know maybe a first-round
talent so something you're doing
something there that has to be credited
to you well I mean I just it's like in
football has always been like this if
things are going well and the head coach
and quarterback are gonna get a lot of
you know a lot of nice attention if
they're going bad it's gonna go the
other way and but you know people that
are in the weeds with it understanding
it takes so much and so many things have
to be in sync for it to work well and I
mean you know we've got a good scheme we
do some we do some good things we've got
a really good creative room as far as
the offensive staff that's able to put
things together and then we've been able
to do it with with really good players
that have also been you know team first
guys and very body in and all those
things together has been a pretty good
combination does it help at all that you
were just a backup quarterback I mean
you were you were not a marquee
quarterback
you know a walk-on you know so do you
see the game differently then if you had
played and started I don't think so
you know I still I feel like still kind
of carry that edge with me you know
maybe you're not being uh yeah maybe
something like that I think there's a
part of that and I you know we've had
some pretty good success you know Baker
being one of them the most you know the
most uh you know we're beard I guess you
would say but the we've had a lot of
great walk-on sort of program I think we
was kind of maybe to look at we look at
that maybe a little bit different maybe
because of some of the history I had
there but no I don't think far seeing
the game any different it would have
been different if I would have you know
played for four years I thank you
you know you just take advantage of
opportunities you have and I had a great
place to learn and and you know I've
always enjoyed the game and get to know
it better how would you assess to your
quarterback talent just throughout my
time here or Mike or my quarterback yeah
when you played I was average athlete I
threw the ball pretty well but then when
I had a pretty major shoulder injury my
sophomore year in high school and it was
a little bit a little bit different
after that so that probably ended ended
any hope that I had of maybe a law
College along college career
he's Lincoln Riley the Oklahoma head
coach joining his Continental Tire
Coach's Corner why do we assume you
would want to coach in the NFL I don't
know I don't know I mean I think I just
think so many people think of it as a
just like a player would a player want
to do well in high school and then go do
well in college and then and in the next
steps in FL they see it as a stepping
stone deal and you know and that is true
for players for coaches it's not and
it's you know there's you know College
in the NFL are similar in a lot of ways
and and I don't know that you could say
one is better than the other
and so I think it comes down to the
individual person but you have a goal
like is that part of the bucket list
checklist no no no that's not I you know
I know I got in this thing you know not
knowing you know expect him to be
expecting to be a high school coach I
mean that's when I thought about my
cooking career you know early on while I
was still playing I mean that's that's
what I wanted to do and you know not
know all the streams because I know or
even think something like this would
have happened so I don't know that I
have a bucket list I mean I just try to
make the most of every situation I've
been in and I know that you know there's
a thousand other people or million other
people that would want to be in the same
situation so I just try to you know try
to appreciate each one for what it is in
that moment yeah it's strange though you
see Spurrier did it and Sabin did it but
then they realized that their college
guys there's certain guys who just are
made to be you know daibo sweeney
strikes me as just a college guy and
that's why when people started
speculating about an NFL job for you and
I said I I don't know if I'd leave
Oklahoma I mean you have everything you
can compete for a national title you get
good players in there you get paid well
so I I don't see the NFL is an end-all
for coaches but you know it's it's to
the individual and that's why I was
wondering because you're young I just
don't know if if you've you know you're
gonna face that soon and then you say to
your wife am I ready for this do I need
this do we want to do this because it'll
be a team with you your wife and
daughters like now all of a sudden it
changes a little bit if you're an NFL
coach is as opposed to a college coach
no question when those guys you know
when those guys are to reference last I
think that was you know the college game
has evolved in a lot of ways as the NFL
and you could sit there and argue good
better and different I mean but a lot of
things change and a lot of things
continue to change and so you know I
think that that always you know maybe
influences your decision-making on them
yeah I think the college game is in such
a great place right now that it's you
know it's second to none and and you
know I'm fortunate enough to be one of
them that's what best places there is
anywhere can you tell Jalen Hurd's to
lighten up after the
his postgame interviews you know when he
runs runs for two and throws for four
and he shows up as if he's gonna get
scolded well he lines up around us so
I'm sorry you guys don't get to see it
yeah but we've had a lot of fun with him
and and you know either part of the part
of that who he is now he's a serious
dude he's he's serious about what he's
knowing it and it's a guy that's been
through a little bit of this before not
this exact same situation but he's been
a part of successful teams and those
knows we've got a lot more out there for
us as a team and he's done a good job
not open set that mentality with this
current team know he seems like a really
good kid and and I meant that as a
compliment it doesn't seem like he's
ever satisfied no he's not he's not and
that's one of the things you love about
him but he he he can appreciate it and
smile and enjoy it and all that you know
probably more than what the public sees
and uh you know let's we've certainly
seen that with him and I've enjoyed you
know that's been one of my main messages
to him the whole time as you know we've
got big goals and things that we know we
can accomplish and it's going to take it
you're having mindset the whole way but
you also have to enjoy this too you know
you only you know you only get so many
of these and for him and for us you know
only one shot at it here and m11 left
for him in the college game so you know
you got to make sure and enjoy it too so
we've you know we've certainly had some
fun along the way
coach Congrats on the success so far
this season and good luck the rest of
the year
Thanks damn appreciate having me on for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]